the silver honors and foreign film go to
Thomas Stuber whose film of dogs and
horses was also made at a German school
but this time at the film Academy Baden
württemberg of dogs and horses is the
story of Rolf and his old dog Pete when
it's discovered that Pete can only
survive with a very expensive operation
Ralph's last resort is a fateful day at
the races there he puts it all on the
line for his beloved dog I need to thank
the Academy for inviting us over here
with our little film of dogs and horses
for bringing us over here I had an
incredible week this is such a
tremendous honor thank you and
furthermore I need to thank my wonderful
actors Matias gonna dance temple and of
course our dog lava unfortunately she
died this past winter and so it was her
first and last ever appearance on the
big screen and it was worth in Student
Academy Awards so louder who ever you
are right now without you we could never
have done this everybody else at the
film Academy at departures Tommy and
Dina filter my DOP paidamma Tesco I just
love working with you my wonderful
editor who's filming right now Phillip
Thomas my producer Pascal I can't see
you there's lights and everything you
don't see anything
my parents especially my mom and last
but not least my girl Miss Sophie she
unfortunately couldn't come with it
because she wouldn't fit on the plane
you know so our very student like two
and a half weeks um I just wanna say
this only what your Sophie only with
your support and understanding I can do
what I love which is making films and I
love